[Music]
hi rob this is tracy penman i am from
phoenix arizona prior i was from seattle
washington huge fan of especially of the
80s movies i loved about last night
question is
um your brother
chad low
i used to see him in more movies i don't
know if he's doing more production work
but why not a movie with rob and chad
lowe in it i think that could be really
fun to see you guys work together like
you do with your son
so that's my question are we going to
see any productions with you and your
brother
thank you love the podcast love your
books
well thank you so much for first of all
for listening and for enjoying the books
um here's what uh is interesting i think
you may have seen a number of robin chad
productions and maybe not known them
because chad lowe is one of the leading
television directors
and has directed multiple episodes of
9-1-1 lone star
coincidentally
directed the first episode that my son
john owen wrote
and that was if you're a lone star fan
it was last year's crossover episode
um that involved the big wildfire
written by my son directed by my brother
and chad does act but not as much
anymore he's really focused on the
directing but i'd like to get him back
in the makeup
i mean you know chad low and makeup is a
thing to behold
and uh i think we need to figure out how
to do that so
um we've always been trying to find
something
and i'm sure that we will at some point
but i love that you're a fan and i will
pass it on